nunca está de más practicar mucho por lo
que en este vídeo are esencialmente un
montón más de lo que llamamos problemas
de divisiones largas entonces sí tienen
2.292 dividido por cuatro
y 2.292 no sé exactamente por qué las
llaman divisiones largas y pensamos un
poco sobre esto en el último vídeo
aquella vez no las llame divisiones
largas pero creo que la razón por la
cual las llaman de ese modo si lo
piensas por un momento es debido a que
toma mucho tiempo y un gran trozo de
papel puede resolverlas y a medida que
avanzan se encontrarán con esta larga
cola que se desarrolla en el problema
así que todas estas al menos son razones
para medel porque se llaman divisiones
largas pero vimos en el último vídeo que
existe una manera de resolver cualquier
división tan sólo con saber las tablas
de multiplicación hasta quizás 10 por 10
o 12 por 12 pero como un repaso esto es
lo mismo que 2.292 dividido por 4
y en realidad se trata de lo mismo
probablemente han visto esta anotación
antes de esta forma 2.292 / 4
esta esta y estas son todas
enunciaciones equivalentes en algún
nivel como podrían observar dirán oye
sol eso parece una fracción en el caso
de que ya han visto las fracciones eso
es exactamente lo que es es una fracción
pero de todas maneras me enfocaré en
este formato y en vídeos futuros
pensaremos en otras formas de
representar las divisiones entonces
vamos a resolverlo
cuántas veces cabe 4 en 2 no cabe
ninguna vez avancemos tan solo
permítanme cambiar el color así que
analicemos el 22 cuántas veces cabe 4 en
22 veamos 4 veces 5 es igual a 20
4 veces 6 es igual a 24 así que 6 es un
número muy alto 4 cabe en el 22 5 veces
5 veces 4 es igual a 20 sobran algunos
números y luego restamos 22 menos 20 es
igual a 2
y luego bajamos este 9
ustedes vieron en el último vídeo lo que
significa esto exactamente cierto cuando
escribieron este 5 de acá arriba noten
que está ubicado es el lugar de la
centena así que éste equivale realmente
a 500
pero en este vídeo me enfocaré más en el
proceso y así podrán pensar más en lo
que realmente significan los lugares de
los números
esperemos que el proceso esté claro
entonces bajamos el 9 cuántas veces cabe
4 en 29 veamos 4 cabe al menos 6 veces 4
veces 7 es igual a 28
4 x 8 32 así que no podemos utilizar el
8 así que utilizaremos el 74 caben 29 7
veces 7 veces 4 es igual a 28 29 menos
28 para obtener nuestro residuo en este
paso del problema es 1
ahora bajamos este 2
lo bajaremos y obtendremos un 12
4 cabe entonces es fácil 4 veces 3 es
igual a 12
4 cabe en 12 3 veces 3 veces 4 es igual
a 12 12 12 0 no nos quedó residuo así
que 4 caben 2.292 exactamente 573 veces
entonces podemos decir que 2.292 / 4 es
igual a 573 o podemos decir que estoy
aquí es igual a 573
hagamos unos cuantos más
hagamos unos pocos problemas más
déjeme elegir un color lindo usar el
rojo digamos que tenemos 7
bain 6.475
tal vez se llaman divisiones largas
porque escribes esta bella y larga línea
de aquí arriba no lo sé existen
múltiples razones por la que se podrían
llamar divisiones largas así que decimos
que 7 caben 60 veces así que tenemos que
continuar ahora vamos con el 64 4 veces
cabe el 7 en el 64 veamos 7 veces 7 es
bueno en este nombre es muy pequeño
siete veces siete es apenas 49 el 63
perdón
siete veces nueve es igual a 63 ese
número está bastante cerca y 7 veces 10
era demasiado grande 7 veces dice es
igual a 70 así que sos demasiado alto 7
kn 64 9 veces
esos 63 y 64 63 para obtener nuestro
residuo en esta etapa es 1
bajemos el 7 cuántas veces cabe 7 en 17
bueno siete veces dos es igual a catorce
y siete veces trece es igual a 21
así que 13 es un número muy grande
entonces 7 caben 17 2 veces 2 por 7 es
14 17 menos 14 es igual a 3
y ahora bajamos el 5
bajamos el 57 caben 35 pero están
nuestras tablas de multiplicar 5 veces 5
por 7 es igual a 35 5 por 7 es igual a
35 y ahí tienen el residuo es 0 todos
los ejemplos que he hecho hasta ahora no
poseen residuo hagamos uno que tal vez
tenga residuo para asegurarme que tenga
residuo
inventaré un ejercicio es mucho más
fácil crear ejercicios que tengan
residuos que los que no los poseen
digamos que quiero dividir
bien
173 50 92 1 millón 735 mil 92 / 3
este será un hermoso y bestial problema
ese es el número que dividiremos por 3
así que tenemos 3 aunque no estoy muy
seguro que este ejercicio posee al
residuo el próximo vídeo te mostraré
cómo saber cuando algo es divisible por
3 de hecho podemos hacerlo ahora mismo
tan sólo suma todos estos dígitos 1 + 7
883 es 11 11 5 es 16 16 más 9 es 25 25 +
12 es 27 así que en realidad este número
es divisible por 3 si sumas todos los
dígitos obtienes 27 y luego pueden sumar
esos dígitos 2 + 7 es igual al 9 así que
es divisible por 9 ese es un truco que
solo sirve con el número 3 así que este
número es realmente divisible por 3 así
que déjenme modificar un poco para que
no sea divisible por 3
déjenme cambiar este número por un 1
ahora este número no será divisible por
3 definitivamente quiere un número que
termine con un residuo solo para que
vean cómo se ve hagamos este 3 cabe en
10 veces así que debemos continuar
podrían escribir un 0 aquí y
multiplicarlo pero eso lo hace un poco
desordenado en mi mente así que tan solo
nos moveremos un lugar a la derecha
cuántas veces cabe 7 en 17
3 x 5 es 15 y 3 por 6 es 18 por lo tanto
es muy grande entonces 3 caben 17 5
veces
5 x 3 es 15 y luego restamos
17 - 15 es igual a 2
ahora bajamos este 3
cuántas veces cabe 3 en 23 bueno 3 veces
7 es igual a 21 y tres veces 8 es muy
grande ya que es igual a 24
3 caben 23 7 veces
7 veces 3 es 21 luego restamos 23 menos
21 y eso es igual a 2
ahora bajamos el siguiente número que es
el 5 creo que pueden apreciar por qué se
llaman divisiones largas bajamos este 5
cuántas veces cabe 3 en 25 bueno tres
veces ocho te da un resultado bastante
cercano mientras que tres veces de nueve
es un número muy grande así lo haremos
con ocho esto es 24 me estoy quedando
sin espacio
si restan obtienen 125 menos 24 es 1
ahora podemos bajar el cero
este 0 así
cuántas veces cabe 3 en 10 esta es muy
fácil cabe 3 veces 3 por 3 9 esto es lo
más cercano a 10 que podemos obtener 3 x
3 es 910 menos nueve tendré que
desplazar hacia arriba un poco en esta
parte y 10 menos 9 es uno y luego
podemos bajar el nuevo número me estoy
quedando sin colores
puedo bajar decir 9 cuántas veces cabe 3
en 19 bueno 6 es el número más cercano
que obtendremos eso nos da 18 así que
tres veces 63 caben 19 6 veces 6 veces 3
dejen de desplazar esto hacia abajo 6
veces 13 es igual a 18 19 menos 18
eso es igual a 1 y ya casi terminamos
volver a usar el color rosado bajamos
este 1 hasta acá
cuántas veces cabe 3 en 11 bueno cabe
tres veces porque tres veces cuatro es
un número muy grande tres veces cuatros
igualados así que es muy grande así que
cabe tres veces tres caben once tres
veces tres veces tres es igual a nueve
luego restamos y obtenemos 12
y ya no tenemos más números para bajar
cuando miramos aquí no tenemos nada más
para bajar así que terminamos así que
quedamos con un residuo de 2 después de
hacer todo este problema la respuesta de
un millón 735 mil 92 dividido por 3 es
578 mil 363 con un residuo de 2
y ese residuo de dos es el que tenemos
hasta acá abajo así que espero que ahora
puedan apreciar y resolver casi
cualquier problema de divisiones y que
también a través de este ejercicio
puedan apreciar por qué se llaman
divisiones largas